the reason we've gone crazy in a word is
sex hi I'm Tracy Oppenheimer with reason
TV and here with Nancy Koehn author of
delirium how the sexual
counter-revolution is polarizing America
Nancy thanks for being here happy to be
here Tracy what is the sexual
counter-revolution and what are these
sexual fundamentalists about 40 years
ago everything changed in America
birth control actually used to be
illegal gay sex was illegal and then you
had the sexual revolution and what
happened a small group of Americans
mostly religious fundamentalists freaked
out about these changes in sexual
relations and personal freedom and they
became politically active exactly and
deliberately to rollback these changes
and you say that these people are the
most powerful bloc in the Republican
Party but they're also a vast minority
how is this possible by doing that
really you know kind of boring and
tedious work of working in your local
party committees at the precinct levels
and state conventions these people that
I call the sexual fundamentalists
constitute about 50 percent of the
Republican electorate now these are
strong identifying Republicans and of
course the activists are much smaller
minority they really became the
gatekeepers of the 2012 primary field
and that is why we're seeing you know
someone like Santorum that is really a
fringe candidate and it's also why Mitt
Romney has been forced to talk about
birth control and abortion much more
than he would want to he would prefer to
talk about the economy do you think that
part of that responsibility lies with
the mainstream media because they've
sort of displayed these sex issues as at
the top it's much more sensational to
talk about sex than it is about deficits
granted but there was actually a lot
more of these social issues coming up in
the Republican primary earlier that the
mainstream media wasn't reporting on the
candidates we're talking a lot about
personhood amendments about the pill is
a form of abortion there's the people
who care about abortion and birth
control and whether or not they should
be legal and then
the group of people who just don't think
the government should be funding it is
this sort of unfairly clumping them I
don't know that I'm unfairly clumping
them the people who feel that way are
joined together in the Republican Party
people who want to see smaller
government who don't believe government
should fund it let's leave aside that
this is about insurance regulations not
the government funding birth control as
well which is another see how that plays
out in the next few years we'll see
Democrats did call it an attack on
reproductive rights when the issue arose
of religious institutions and companies
don't want to pay for birth control most
of the people agitating this are
reactionaries about sexual issues and
people who disagree with this on issues
of government regulation and religious
liberty didn't do enough to challenge
their political allies do you still
think the government should be providing
funding for these programs
we're the only advanced country in the
world that doesn't have a real system of
universal health care and I think it's a
travesty that we allow people to die
because they don't have the money by
just focusing on birth control I do
think it's a fundamental issue of
personal freedom and I do think it's a
fundamental issue of health if we are
going to have regulation because they're
not paying for it doesn't mean well it's
do it yes
some forms of birth control happen to be
very expensive if we are going to have
any kind of regulation of health care
that should be one of the covered
services you also acknowledge that
Republicans aren't the only ones to
blame here I could you talk a little bit
about the Democrats or all classic New
Deal liberals I had the same kind of
reaction against these new issues of sex
and women's rights and gay rights coming
up in the party every time that
Democrats lose election except recently
they revert to this kind of collective
panic that it must be the fault of our
base it must be the women it must be the
gays it must be the
this college students thank you again
for coming and talking to us you're
welcome it's pleasure to be your reason
TV I'm Tracy Oppenheimer
you